en primer lugar Cuáles son las
principales crisis que afectan a las
infancias del mundo
Buenas tardes es un gusto estar con
ustedes pues muchas de estas crisis las
hemos las hemos estado viviendo la
primera esta que todavía no terminamos
de cerrar pero que ojalá esté ya en sus
últimas etapas es la crisis del Coby
tenemos además el cambio climático Y
tenemos además el tema de las
migraciones Eso sin contar por supuesto
un escenario económico en los en estos
años y probablemente a mediano plazo
crisis un escenario económico no de
crecimiento desacelerado y ciertamente
de menor márgenes Fiscales sobre todo
aquí en
América Latina maneja cifras sobre el
número de niños y niñas que carecen de
servicios de protección social esencial
Sí hoy por hoy para la región tenemos
que el 40% de los hogares sin niños
carecen de protección social y dada la
importancia de la protección social
sobre todo para la infancia no en tanto
no no solamente el el asegurar ingresos
ingresos dignos y no la importancia de
la protección social
por los múltiples efectos
multidimensionales para el desarrollo de
los niños esto pues es una situación que
estamos llamados
hablemos un poco de las consecuencias a
Qué riesgos quedan expuestos los niños y
niñas
el no tener protección social significa
que los niños no tienen ingresos dignos
para vivir significa una menor nutrición
significa un menor acceso a educación
peores resultados en salud peores
resultados en lo que se refiere a
trabajo infantil cuando las familias no
cuentan con ingresos dignos se llevan a
cabo todas estas estrategias no de
mitigación de esta situación como por
ejemplo el tema del trabajo infantil o
el tema de las uniones tempranas es es
importante por tanto que la protección
social está en el centro es la discusión
es de política y como parte de cualquier
estrategia de desarrollo del arte Cuáles
son las regiones más vulnerables
hoy por hoy después del realmente todo
el mundo está en una situación compleja
como les decía mencionaba yo de menor
crecimiento de menores espacios Fiscales
no donde el tema de aumentar la
protección social de la infancia
infancia que siempre está sobre
representada en lo que tiene que ver con
pobreza es una tarea que el mundo tiene
pendiente
dentro de la región no nosotros tenemos
que el y la recesión ha afectado de
manera diferenciada los países pero sin
lugar a dudas todos los países de
América Latina están llamados en este
momento no solamente atender viejas
vulnerabilidades no Nosotros sabemos que
esta región es una región que por
ejemplo se caracteriza por brechas
permanentes con población y la población
indígena Apolo a población
afrodescendiente no mujeres no que sobre
todo después de covid se han visto
cargadas con el tema del cuidado no la
población en situación de informalidad
laboral tenemos estas brechas que ya
conocíamos de antes pero ahora además no
tenemos estas múltiples crisis no que
llaman a los gobiernos no a una mayor
atención al tema de protección social y
del financiamiento también del claro